m
dans le cadre de la semaine du
développement durable le conservatoire
botanique national de mascarin a
organisé une visite guidée sur le thème
des fruits et légumes oubliés de la
réunion qui dit développement durable
dit aussi une consommation qui doit être
un petit peu diversifiée une
consommation qui dit ne pas avoir tout
temps des habitués comme je dis bah là
c'est bien de présenter des fruits comme
un aimant bolo sanou connais pas trop le
mans boloni oublie manger des fruits à
pain lave avant et donc du coup tout ça
n'oublie nous laisse un petit peu de
côté et nous ça va nous dit à nous
prendre notre pomme pomme banane et
voilà alors que nous on a une grande
diversité à la réunion nous n'est seul
très riche nous peut avoir de multiples
légumes de multiples fruits et avant une
grande diversité dans nos assiettes donc
c'est amener un petit peu au travers de
cette visite de réfléchir un petit peu
sur nos consommations actuelles
un véritable moment d'échangé de
convivialité
sarah fontaine a su enchanter le public
en transmettant son savoir de manière
ludique et interactive
une belle occasion pour découvrir ou
redécouvrir les fruits et légumes lontan
dans un jardin d'exception
ben moi j'ai trouvé très intéressante
c'est qu'on n'entend pas souvent parler
des délais du montant et le volant plus
vu que marcher dans l'agriculture
bah c'est super intéressant de voir
qu'il ya plein de plein de variétés en
fait qui existe et dont on n'entend pas
beaucoup plus que ça parlait quoi ah ben
moi je trouve ça très sympa elle et elle
est vivante et tous et interactif on
pose des questions elle répond bien
comme comme il faut non cdph envoyé des
petits exemples aussi mais j'aime bien
entendu causer créole aussi c'est
important je veux c'est cet aspect
culturel aussi et donc avaient toutes
les expressions qui sont liés voilà aux
fruits et légumes lontan danser j'ai
beaucoup aimé
j'aime beaucoup l'éloquence avec
laquelle notre cher ami ici présentes
s'exprime
on voit que les passionnés voilà un
commentateur passionné et passionnant
c'est important toujours toujours là
pour répondre aux questions et ré
entraîner avec avec ce qui se passe le
conseil départemental de la réunion se
mobilisent et agit depuis de nombreuses
années en faveur du développement
durable